let me ask
one other ridiculous question
we talked about the death
and life cycle that is ever present in
the universe until it's not until it's
super massive and little black holes too
at the end of the universe what do you
think
is the why the meaning of it all
what do you think is the meaning of life
here on earth
and the meaning of that life that you
look for
whether it's on venus or other
exoplanets
i think there's none i find enormous
relief
in the absence of meaning i think
chasing from meaning is
a human desire the universe doesn't give
two shits about
[Laughter]
but you still enjoy i enjoy finding
meaning in my life
i enjoy finding
where the morality lies i enjoy the
complication of
that desire and i
feel that is deeply human but i don't
feel that it's universal
it's somehow absolute like we conjure it
up we it
we we bring it to life through our own
minds but it's not any kind of
fundamental way real
no and the same way the sun
is not to be blamed for destroying its
own planets
the universe doesn't care because it has
no meaning
it owes us nothing and looking for
meaning in the universe is demanding
answers who are we we're nothing we
don't get to demand anything
and that includes meaning and i find it
very reassuring
because once there is no meaning i don't
have to find it
[Laughter]
uh yeah once there's no meaning it's a
it's a kind of freedom in a way you
sound a bit like um
[Music]
i'm happy about it this isn't a
depressing outlook as far as i'm
concerned
it's happiness yeah yeah so i mean
there's a i don't know if you know who
sam harris is but he
uh despite the pushbacks from
the entirety of the world really argues
hard that there's
that free will is an illusion that um
you know the the the
deterministic universe and it's all
already been predetermined and
and he's okay with it and he's happy
with it that that
he's distinctly aware of it and that's
the world will disagree with him on the
deterministic nature
of nature well he's uh
it's not the he's not saying it's
deterministic but he's saying that the
randomness doesn't
help either like randomness does not
help in uh in the experience
of feeling like you're the decider of
your own actions
that he kind of is okay with being a
leaf flowing on the river
like or being the river right as opposed
to having or being like a fish or
something they can decide it's
swimming direction he's okay just
embracing the flow of life i mean in
that same way
it kind of sounds like your conception
of
meaning i mean it just is it doesn't
the universe doesn't care it just is
what it is and we experience certain
things
and some feel good and some don't and uh
that's life but i don't feel like that
about life i think life does have
meaning and there's and it's laudable to
look for that meaning in life
i just don't think you can apply that
beyond
life and certainly not be on earth that
this
notion of meaning is a human construct
and so
it only applies within us and
the other life forms and planet
types that suffer from our intrusions or
rejoice from our interactions but
it's this this meaning is ours to do as
we please
we created it we've created a need for
it and so
that's our problem to solve i don't
apply it beyond us
i think we as humans have a lot of
responsibilities but they're moral
responsibilities
and a lot of the responsibilities are
much more easily fulfilled
if you find meaning in them so i think
there's value to meaning
whether it's real or not i just think we
gain nothing from trying to
anthropomorphize the entire universe and
also
that's the height of hubris that's not
for us to do
yeah it also could be just like duality
in quantum mechanics
it could uh it could be both that there
is meaning
and then there isn't and we're somehow
depending on uh the observer
depending on the the perspective you
take on the thing
i mean even on earth that's true but the
whether things are meaning or not
depends a lot on who's looking
whether it's us humans the aliens or the
giraffes
clara this was a incredible conversation
i i mean i i learned so much but i also
am just inspired by the passion you have
in um not finding meaning in the
universe yeah
right for someone i'm very passionate
about not finding meaning in the
universe
you're the most inspiring nihilist i've
ever met i'm just kidding
uh this you're i mean you are truly an
inspiring communicator
of everything from phosphine to life to
quantum astro chemistry i can't wait to
see what other cool things you do
in your career in your in your
scientific life thank you so much
for wasting your valuable time with me
today i really appreciate it
uh it was my pleasure i had already got
my four hours of productivity before i
got here and so
it's not a waste it's all downhill from
there thank you
you